with zach and cody i know it was only
one episode there but of course you
eventually went on to have a much more
substantial role in other shows so is
there anything
that you took from seeing dylan and cole
kind of lead a show and be such a big
part of it that
you took on with you to your more
substantial projects
that's a great question i mean i think i
learned from every job that i work on
i was so young we were all so young i
was i think 11 or
i think i was 11 when i was on that show
it might have been like my first guest
starring role
it was certainly my first kiss with cole
i'll never forget that
um but no i mean i think just watching
them
you just they
they just did such a great job and
there's there's a lot to balance you
know when you're a kid and you're doing
you're trying to get all your hours of
school work in
and then you know you're also working
these long hours and then you're also
trying to find time to still be like a
normal kid and like hang out with
friends and
i've always admired that about dylan and
cole is that like even though
they've been in the spotlight since they
were so young and are so famous
they're so normal like when you hang out
with them they're not
they're just super grounded down to
earth
cool guys and their parents um their dad
specifically i think has always
like made it that way for them and um
i always admired that a lot is it safe
to assume
that your mom kind of filled that role
for you
definitely oh yeah yeah my mom my mom
and i are super close and my mom would
come to set with me
all the time and my mom has always been
very involved in my career and in my
life and both my parents have been i'm
so lucky to have two
incredibly supportive amazing parents i
mean it's you know it's not
every day that you know your parents
will just
be like yeah let's take a shot on our
kid and like
you know my wife and and my my daughter
are just gonna move to la
and like they're gonna go for it and
we're gonna fly out there and and
and it seems to be going pretty well so
we're gonna move out there too and see
how it goes you know it's pretty crazy
it's
i feel very lucky that they believed in
me and i also feel very lucky that
they're such like
grounded they're just very grounded
centered people
[Music]
[Applause]